أسماك قرش الكوكايين الآن قبل أن تحكموا علي،
أعطوني ثانية لأن العلماء
يبحثون فيما إذا كانت أسماك القرش
تتعاطى الكوكايين بعد أن قام مهربو المخدرات
بإلقاء الكوكايين في المحيط محاولين
التهرب من السلطات، وقد لاحظ علماء الأحياء البحرية
بعض السلوكيات الغريبة، ألقِ
نظرة،
لاحظت كيف هي  السباحة
نعم، يبدو أنها من
جهة واحدة قليلًا كما لو كانت مثقلة للأسفل،
وهي ليست في المستوى تمامًا
الآن، وهذا أمر غير معتاد يمكن أن يكون إصابة سابقة
أو ربما خللًا في التوازن الكيميائي في كلتا الحالتين، هناك
شيء يجب ملاحظته بالتأكيد،
حتى أسماك القرش لديها
اختلالات كيميائية تنضم إلي  الآن من
اكتشافات الشبكة الشقيقة، أسماك
قرش الكوكايين، علماء الأحياء في الحياة البرية وخبير Shark
Week في Escalante، شكرًا
جزيلاً لوجودكم هنا، مرحبًا سارة،
كيف حالك،
يبدو الأمر جنونيًا،
أسماك قرش الكوكايين لا أعرف، أنا فقط أقول إن هذا
يجعلني أشعر بالقلق من أن الناس
سأعتقد أنني مجنون ولكن كيف يكون هذا
احتمالًا
حسنًا لكي أكون واضحًا أه إنه جنون أعني أن
ما يحدث كما يمكنك أن تتخيل أن
البشر لهم تأثير كبير على
البيئة بغض النظر عما نفعله أو
أين نذهب وماذا  من المحتمل أنك قد
ترى في هذا المقطع والذي من الواضح أنه
ليس لدي أي علاقة به، حيث
قد يكون لأسماك القرش نوع من التأثير من
المخدرات والمواد الصيدلانية الأخرى في
الماء، كما تعلم أننا رأينا ذلك في أماكن
في جنوب فلوريدا بونفيش في  على وجه الخصوص،
هناك اختبارات عالية بشكل لا يصدق
لمضادات الاكتئاب التي تم إلقاؤها
في المحيط وأجزاء أخرى من
المحيط، وهناك أدوية أخرى
يتم امتصاصها من
خلال السلسلة الغذائية ومن خلال
الجلد وتتراكم تلك المواد الحيوية بحيث
تأكل أسماك القرش في النهاية هذه المواد
قد تعاني الأسماك في الواقع من بعض العواقب السلبية